Does size really matter?
Evolution says it might.
Hello, men and women of Earth.
Trace here,
reporting for D News.
A new study was released today
that shows and grows the belief
that size does matter,
evolutionarily speaking.
But does it?
Of all primates, humans
have the largest penis,
gorillas have the smallest.
And science wondered
why that would be.
Now, we have an idea.
The ladies pick their mates
prior to having sex with them.
The researchers showed women
computer animated male figures
accounting for traits
normally associated
with male attractiveness,
like height and shoulder
to hip ratio.
But they added in
flaccid penis size.
Everyone finds taller
men more attractive.
It's just generally accepted.
But when paired with the ideal
body ratio and a larger penis
size, attractiveness increased.
In a nutshell, the results
found that flaccid penis size
did affect levels of
attraction for women.
Taller dudes with
larger flaccid penises
were considered more attractive.
The scientists
wanted to know, why
are our penises larger
relative to the size
than other primates,
and if females
can affect the evolution of
the male member in a species.
Yes, in a nutshell.
Female sexual
selection can influence
the size of a phallus over time.
Girl power.
Simply put, before we
started wearing clothes
170,000 years ago, the
females of our species
would mate with males who
had larger flaccid penises.
As the selection
continued, generation
over generation, human
penises gradually got larger.
It seems like a win-win to me.
Guys, this is important.
Flaccid penises range in size.
And if you're really concerned
about the size of your member,
you're probably thinking
of it when it's erect.
The average erect penis
is around 5 1/2 inches,
perhaps because of evolution
cultivated a phallus that best
fit with the size of the vagina,
which is about four inches.
But this study only tested
flaccid penises, not
erect ones.
The Kinsey Institute points
out that the averages
for flaccid penises are
like one to four inches,
whereas erect is
between five and seven,
the smaller flaccid
penises increasing
in size way more
than the larger.
Why should we evolutionarily
look for size to matter?
A study published in The
Journal of Sexual Medicine
indicates that women report
having more frequent orgasms
with larger penises.
But the obsession
over size shrinks
when you look at a
myriad of studies
that show the best predictor
of sexual satisfaction
is enjoying the company
of the person attached
to the penis, not the actual
penis attached to the person.
In worthwhile relationships
and attachments,
confidence and attraction wins
over big dongs every time.
For me, the study seems to
miss the idea surrounding
forcible mate selection in
the history of our evolution.
Were females hundreds of
thousands of years ago free
to select mates as they wished?
This might be a little
over sharing for some,
but does size matter to you?
What's the big deal?
Tell us your stories
in the comments.
And before you zoom
off to find a ruler,
make sure you follow us on
Twitter and find us on Facebook
and Google+.
Thanks for watching everybody.
I'm Trace.
See you next time.